[Musique]
de retour sur cette université des
mairies 2018 à port marly qui nous
reçoit pour cette édition spéciale cette
journée spéciale sur tv soixante dix
huit les différents ateliers vont
reprendre ici les participants vont
rejoindre les tables rondes et puis nous
nous allons continuer nos émissions tout
au long de l'après-midi j'accueille à
présent valérie pécresse bonjour et
bienvenue jean piot présidente de la
région ile de france catherine arenou
maire de chanteloup les vignes
bonjour à vous et puis françois elia
bonjour bonjour et au directeur régional
adjoint de la banque des territoires en
ile de france la caisse des dépôts et on
va évoquer avec vous les quartiers en
difficulté ou plutôt comment aider ses
quartiers en difficulté une
problématique plus tôt plus le plutôt
large pour bien définir déjà ces
quartiers on parle de ces endroits où il
ya une action globale de l'état de la
région des communes pour aider les
populations sans emploi avec là des
revenus faibles et qui peinent à accéder
à l'éducation au logement ou encore à la
culture catherine arenou vous avez reçu
le premier ministre et quelques jours
edouard philippe et est venu vous voir
sur le terrain vous avez pu échanger
autour des éventuelles difficultés que
vous rencontrez déjà comment s'est
passée cette échange et puis quelles
sont les difficultés que vous lui avez
remontée du terrain change vous imaginez
bien c'est très bien passé qu'est ce
qu'on peut lui montrer un premier
ministre qui n'est que l'ivresse que
lorsqu'il est là avec 150 personnes
accompagnant ce qu'il faut c'est vivre
le territoire
vive le territoire c'est vivre à la fois
des gens qui sont d'une grande espérance
pour leurs enfants souvent d'avoir
d'avoir un espèce de parcours est ce
qu'on appelle l'ascenseur l'ascension
sociale chez nous ça existe encore non
seulement ça existe encore mais c'est
encore porté par beaucoup de parents de
jeunes parents on a cette chance là mais
on le porte comment on le porte en
accompagnant l'éducation à l'éducation
des enfants et donc du coup on ne fait
pas dans un dirigeant comme le mien on
ne fait pas que faire des écoles on
essaye accompagné par d'autres niveaux
de collectivités on essaye d'accompagner
l'éducation plus haut niveau on essaye
d'accompagner l'emploi plus haut niveau
et puis on essaye d'accompagner les
conditions de vie les conditions de vie
c'est le logement c'est la mobilité là
je pense que valérie nous en prendre à
vous allez nous parler un petit peu des
dispositifs de la région mais déjà
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment d'être
entendu
aidé de par l'état ou d'agir un petit
peu seul malgré tout un rousse avait un
temps qu'on est écoutée on a le
sentiment que tout va aller mieux
lorsque ça s'arrête à l'ecoute bon voilà
je ne fais pas de procès d'intention en
tout cas il a très bien des côtés il a
vu les difficultés pas seulement les
difficultés de des associations sur
place les difficultés de du personnel
municipal sur place qui est souvent
confronté à tous et qui portent souvent
beaucoup de choses et puis mais aussi la
difficulté des pompiers difficultés
d'une police municipale d'une police
nationale qui vit qui sur ces
territoires la même s'ils sont pas
extrêmement grand qui vit toutes les
difficultés que vit la police
actuellement pas de matériel un matériel
vétuste une incapacité
pratiquement il ya suffisamment de
personnel pour faire des actions il ya
plus les véhicules pour les porter par
exemple ça le premier ministre l'a
entendu il s'est simplement des moyens
financiers c'est même pas une nouvelle
politique c'est simplement comprendre
que pour faire que pour que la police
fait son travail très correctement et
moyens et soi et soi à capter accompagne
par exemple accompagne les pompiers qui
aurait imaginé qu'à 25 ans pour un
sauvetage à personne les pompiers besoin
d'être accompagné par la police mais
c'est ça maintenant notre société c'est
ça il faut s'en donner les moyens parce
que sinon ça ne pourra pas durer tenir
très longtemps
valérie pécresse tout à l'heure lors de
votre discours devant les maires réunis
vous avez égrène est un petit peu tous
les dispositifs qui aide qui peuvent
aider que la région peut mettre en place
et ils sont nombreux pour la région ile
de france
mais nous on a d'abord défini une
stratégie on la définit avec jean louis
borloo et les maires au moment où jean
louis atta a réfléchi justement à ce que
pourrait être un plan banlieue du 21e
siècle
la stratégie de la région elle se
décline en trois mots d'ordre la mixité
la réussite est l'autorité la mixité
c'est essayer de reconstruire ses
quartiers en y mettant en y ramenant les
classes moyennes et ça ça veut dire
mettre moins logement social au même
endroit essayez d'arriver à des
quartiers qui sont plus près de 30 % de
logement social nous on a mis un plafond
on aide à construire des nouveaux
quartiers mais on veut 30 % seulement de
logement très social dans ces quartiers
pas plus pour que les classes moyennes
reviennent dans les quartiers et qui est
une vraie mixité ça passe aussi par
l'offre de transport parce qu'il faut
désenclaver pour que les familles
puissent venir pour que les cadres
puissent venir parce qu'un quartier où
il ya plus de mixité comme ce qu'on a
construit qui sont ghettoïsés c'est un
quartier où les professeurs ne veulent
plus enseigner ou donc il n'y a plus
d'espoir pour les familles de
d'ascenseur social pour leurs enfants
et donc on a besoin de cette mixité
ensuite on a besoin de réussir
et ça c'est toute l'aide qu'on fait aux
autres preneurs des cités c'est toute
l'aide qu'on fait aux élèves la lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire mais aussi
nos cités ont du talent c'est à dire
aussi aider les meilleurs
l'une des deux moments qui sont les plus
forts pour moi dans l'année c'est quand
je remets une bourse de 1000 euros à des
bacheliers défavorisés mention très bien
ou quand je remets une bourse de 1000
euros à des adultes qui reprennent des
études pour passer le bac
au cours de leur vie vous et je pense
que la deuxième chance c'est très
important notamment dans ces quartiers
populaires et puis y'a l'autorité et
catherine r nous l'a dit nous tous les
équipements de sécurité qui nous sont
demandées aujourd'hui la région finance
la vidéoprotection l'équipement des
polices tout ce qui peut la sécurisation
des lycées la sécurisation des
transports on a mis des policiers et les
agents de sécurité dans les bus ont fait
arrêter et c'est à la demande de femmes
de chanteloup de la cité de la noé que
je fais aujourd'hui arrêter une
expérimentation les bus la nuit à la
demande
parce que les femmes qui se lèvent très
tôt pour aller travailler souvent en
horaires décalés qui rentrent très tard
elles ont des bus jusqu'à presque deux
heures du matin mais elles ont peur de
faire le trajet est donc maintenant on
lance et on va la généraliser une
expérimentation d'arrêt
à la demande des bus donc vous voyez
c'est la question comment est ce qu'on
fait pour que cette vie quotidienne
elles soient apaisées elles soit pacifié
et qu'elles permettent de réussir c'est
juste une parenthèse parce que vous
parler d'autorité il ya quelques jours
vous avez évoqué cette double peine en
quelque sorte dans certains des
certaines des zones des quartiers pour
nous développer un petit peu revenir sur
cette déclaration
oui moi ce qui m'apparaît aujourd'hui
c'est que les habitants des quartiers
les plus criminogènes et tous les
quartiers populaires sont pas des
quartiers criminogènes ces deux choses
différentes ya des quartiers qui sont
aujourd'hui livrés à la guerre des gangs
et à la guerre des bandes autour on va
le dire du trafic de drogue et dans ces
quartiers les policiers ne peuvent plus
entrer le samu ne peut plus rentrer les
médecins peuvent plus rentrer vous savez
qu'il ya certains quartiers dans
lesquels le samu doit mettre des gilet
pare balles bon donc là il ya une
logique de reconquête de rétablissement
de l'ordre
c'est ce qu'a d'ailleurs digère piccolo
c'est cette jarre colons en partant mais
on parle d'une marche i minorité de
quartier dans ces quartiers là je
considère qu'il faut qu'on protège les
habitants
la loi pénale ne s'applique pas avec la
même rigueur dans ces quartiers là
qu'elle s'applique ailleurs tout
simplement parce que bas parce que c'est
un tonneau des danaïdes c'est en
permanence et donc les policiers baisse
les bras
les juges prononcent des peines mais
elles sont pas toujours exécuté puisque
nos prisons sont pleines
donc le sujet c'était aujourd'hui de
dire de durcir le ton et de dire eh ben
dans ces quartiers là il y aura une
circonstance aggravante dans les
quartiers où les la délinquance et le
double de la moyenne nationale y aura
une circonstance aggravante si on commet
un acte dans ces quartiers là on sera on
sera on aura une peine qui pourrait
double peine parce que parce que comme
ça
eh bien on arrivera peut-être enfin à le
donner le message que l'impunité c'est
fini et qu'il faut arrêter
françois lien je me tourne vers vous on
va pas parler de double peine en cette
fois ci avec vous avec la caisse des
dépôts jouets savoir de quelle manière
vous vous intervenez que les
téléspectateurs et téléspectatrices qui
nous suivent comprennent un petit peu de
quel est votre rôle dans tout ce
dispositif dès des deux dispositifs qui
existent
la caisse des dépôts la banque des
territoires aujourd'hui est au service
des collectivités territoriales donc le
partenariat que nous avons avec les
collectivités que ce soit la région les
départements les communes
c'est un partenaire de très long terme
et qui a pris une forme plus formel à
partir de 2004 dans le prolongement des
actions engagées sur le programme de
rénovation urbaine
alors pour faire simple parce que je
veux pas citer trop de chiffres mais
tout de même puisque c'est l'une l'un de
nos modes d'intervention sur le premier
programme de rénovation urbaine pour
l'île de france c'est plus de 5
milliards de financements qui ont été
mobilisés par la caisse des dépôts par
la banque des territoires mais ça ne
suffit pas ça n'est qu'une étape
à nous le savons ce qui a été fait par
les élus locaux c'est formidable en
termes d'habitat en termes de
réaménagement des espaces publics mais
nous le savons nous le constatons en
contact avec les élus locaux avec les
partenaires au projet il nous reste deux
grandes choses à faire notamment en
matière de développement économique
la présidente l'évoquait en matière de
formation de mobilité puisque très
souvent les quartiers sont un petit peu
excentré très souvent l'accès aux
transports est plus complexe et donc
nous avons voilà un certain nombre de
sujets qui sont identifiés par les
territoires par les élus que la banque
des territoires accompagne avec donc un
volet financier que j'évoquais
rapidement et puis également et surtout
peut-être un volant d'ingénierie et
d'expertisé
c'est cette capacité que nous avons à la
banque des territoires a mobilisé des
hommes et des femmes qui apportent une
vision une expertise pour mettre en
oeuvre les projets des territoires de la
meilleure des manières en termes de
robustesse
quels sont les projets peut-être qui
peuvent exister ou la banque des
territoires intervient sur notre commune
par commune mais c'est vrai qu'on l'a
vécu dans le cas d'un plan de rénovation
urbaine numéro un mais c'est vrai que la
spécificité de ces territoires lorsqu'on
veut vraiment s'y atteler et si souvent
plusieurs collectivités trc la région
l'état très difficilement mais c'est la
région c'est le département c'est les
opci et c'est les villes se sait
généralement un projet global est un
projet global on a besoin de
l'ingénierie et on a besoin bien
évidemment de finir mon sort mais on a
surtout besoin d'un générique
parce que dans des quartiers comme les
notes tout et en tout si on refait de
l'éducation ont refait de l'éducation en
considérant que le temps de l'enfance et
pas seulement le temps de l'éducation
donc vous faire du périscolaire aussi
donc vous faire de l'accompagnement
sportif de qualité offert de
l'accompagnement culture
de qualité donc il faut faire aussi par
exemple une bibliothèque mais au-delà de
ça il faut faire après qu'est ce qu'ils
deviennent donc il faut porter la
formation donc c'est vrai on ne peut pas
se contenter d'avoir un projet qui va
occuper un mandat c'est un projet global
parce qu'ils considèrent en fait les
habitants pratiquement de leur naissance
jusqu'au moment ils peuvent voler de
leurs propres ailes et leur difficulté
c'est de voler de leurs propres ailes
les projets sont nombreux vous l'avez
entendu mais après est-ce que les
résultats sont évalués aussi est ce que
par exemple du côté de la région vous
regardez un petit peu ce qui marche qui
marche pas ce qu'on peut améliorer
alors on est venu annoncer des projets
on est enfin on est en train de s'y
mettre par exemple les missions locales
c'est une très belle idée les missions
locales pour l'emploi des jeunes il ya
des missions locales qui marche très
très bien là des missions locales qui
insère qui font des très bons résultats
et puis à des missions locales un peu
plan-plan houba finalement on attend que
le jeune vienne et puis y'a rien de
proactif qui est fait il ya quoi sceller
aux personnes qui tiennent la structure
c lire la structure qui n'est pas adapté
aux lieux où elles se sentent liés aux
personnes mais ça peut surtout être lieu
au manque de directives et au manque
d'évaluation parce que si on vous dit
pas quels sont vos critères de réussite
ben voila vous n'êtes pas forcément
mobilisés sur ces critères donc nous par
exemple avec l'état et en partenariat
avec les villes on a mis en place un
contrat pour que les missions locales
soient mieux accompagnés pour le pôle
emploi mais on fait c'est ce qu'a dit
catherine nous on est sur tous les
domaines de la vie la région on est à la
fois dans l'aide aux mères sur tous les
équipements de proximité culture sport
scolaire
on est aussi l'aide aux associations
pour tout ce qui est social et
solidarité
mais on est aussi sur le dur et c'est là
qu'on travaille avec la caisse des
dépôts notamment par exemple sur la
rénovation des copropriétés dégradées ou
sur la rénovation urbaine parce que
c'est évident que la première chose
c'est d'abord de ramener de la dignité
aux quartiers aux qui doit être qui doit
être vraiment digne voilà on doit avoir
envie d'habiter très bien merci beaucoup
à tous les trois ans d'avoir participé à
cette table ronde à cette émission
delattre notre journée spéciale
universités des mairies se poursuit sur
tv 78 ce sera dans une dizaine de
minutes avec un patrice carmouze et ses
invités il sera question de la gestion
des décès des déchets pardon sauvage
[Musique]